we're shooting a video trying out like
different hats and stuff how do you
think i look uh it's a hat how do you
think i look
today the try guys are going bald which
is something that happens to most men
are you guys ready to get bald i was
born bald i'm ready to be bald again
going bald for me it's not a question of
if it's probably a question of when hair
loss runs in my family it's something
that is happening to me it's very common
among jewish men do you think that's why
jews started wearing yamakas just to
cover up their bald spot there was a
long time that i didn't care about my
hair and i didn't care about it until i
realized i was losing it i looked back
at photos i'm like oh it's going so it's
something i've been trying to combat but
it's also something i've been trying to
come to terms with it makes me feel bad
i have a little bit of thinning starting
here i guess going bald crosses my mind
every so often here's the thing i'm
afraid that my head is an ugly lump of
skin i think my main concern is that i
have this mole on the back of my head
that you've never seen likely because i
always make sure my hair is cut long
enough to cover that mold i don't care
that much about my actual hair but i do
care how i look and being bald with a
big mole on my head would change how i
look i will i don't know i'll be ugly my
grandfather has lost a lot of his hair
so it's probably something that's in my
future to just jump straight to what i'm
gonna look like 50 years from now that's
gonna be shocking my fear today is that
my wife is gonna think i'm hideous
because when you're in love with someone
like i love you no matter what you look
like but now we're gonna test that
assumption will she still find me
attractive i don't know i think when
people describe me physically the first
thing they say is hair second probably
asian but first i'd say hair when i was
young when i felt very unattractive the
one thing people always said to me was i
had great hair so i kind of had this
attachment to it my hair is kind of like
another appendage kind of like the boobs
of my head so like eyes down here i just
have very specific features that look
really stern my personality is softened
by the way my hair is presented and i
feel like without my hair i'm not gonna
be me
[Music]
today what i'm interested to see is what
would i actually look like when i'm bald
because maybe it's not so bad let's do
this three two one
a nightmare oh wow that that is one ugly
fella it's not as bad as i thought it
would be it's a lot smoother than i
thought oh what a duo
that's a feeling that most big but
that's sort of like how i fear my mole
to appear my ears are so much more
prominent you know if it's not one
insecurity it's another all right i'm
ready
holy [ __ ]
oh no i don't i don't like that at all
it looks like a different person i've
never seen myself without hair this just
isn't me it doesn't feel like my
personality i'm astounded i've never
been this floored by a transformation i
look like every martial arts character
like i'm gonna kill somebody
okay i'm done so my father has kind of
more of like around the side i'm gonna
try and get as close to that today as we
can the hope is a sexy bruce willis or a
vin diesel type i'd probably look more
like a baby turtle let's meet future
zack
oh no
oh man i look like dr phil and the kid
from jerry maguire had a baby there are
no words for how much i dislike this
this is a real hit to my confidence guys
how can i look like this and confidently
talk to people i'm really pretty
speechless
i'm pretty stunned
look confidence is sexy right so if i'm
gonna rock the fryer tuck haircut then
you can call me fire [ __ ] one
two
three
oh
no oh
[Music]
oh isn't that sad like why do i just
feel awful about myself just because my
hair changed oh i don't want to be
friends with myself let's check out the
back
sexy
she's not going to like this she's going
to be horrified what if i actually lose
my hair and then
and then she divorces me because she
thinks i'm ugly i'm being silly but also
somewhat serious
i just want to crawl into bed and not
wake up as much as guys like to act like
they don't care about how their hair
looks i think every guy really truly
deeply cares about what the hair looks
like it's way more deep than we allow
ourselves to admit as a society
especially as men we're stepping into a
lot of different shoes here not only
into male insecurity but there's a lot
of people out there when it comes to
cancer alopecia who can't control the
fact that they are losing hair i'm
interested to see
how people were reacting i'm not looking
forward to what everyone else is going
to think and say about this
we're going to the office to see how
people like how i look i think it's kind
of getting used to it all right i'm
gonna go show some friends what i look
like you've done some things in your day
this is not one of them that you should
be doing
[Music]
do you think some people look okay as
bald men yeah not me this is like
divorce for a week no one can pull this
off
what do you think
i think that was my honest opinion yeah
eugene without hair a dream come true
right here what's the dream i secretly
pray that your hair falls out everywhere
this is terrible this is just bad for
everybody
yeah disgusting i was really looking
forward to my coworkers you know kind of
helping me telling me that it was okay
to be faulting that i'm still beautiful
uh so far that has not happened the
opposite has happened i feel awful i
look like a bald thomas jefferson fact
is i don't give a [ __ ] what people think
if this is how i look you can you don't
deserve me in my words can't handle me
at my best the more i see it the less
i'm as upset
by all of us
you look really good you look so good i
think i look really mean of course
yeah of course
this is amazing how do you feel
actually now that i'm walking around
more i kind of enjoy it you look dope
why does he look cool still i felt like
hair was like 90 of it but it's not what
do you think i think you have a really
good shaped head yeah it was the thing
that i was worried about when i was
going bald yeah
you're the first person to compliment me
oh really when did you go bald uh i
started going ball when i was 21 21 yeah
really young but you look great well
thank you i have no problem with that
this looks like i just don't know how i
feel about the ponytail now that i know
that like my head doesn't have any like
lumps or anything i would get a lot of
haircuts like very tight this works for
you like if you have to shave your head
you're going to be i'm going to be okay
even if people are shocked don't give a
[ __ ]
you've been so confident throughout this
whole thing i'm going to see you like in
a suit now i don't know how earl's going
to feel about it when does she see it um
yeah shortly so i'm back at home and i'm
going to
surprise ariel
with my new look so i'm standing on a
street corner
as cars go by to see if anybody gives me
a second look i guess without hair i
don't really need to deal with this
section now i can go to what's most
important
bam we give myself a haircut kind of
putting the control back in my hands
we're gonna see if people react to me a
little better i feel like i look like a
respectable dad you look so happy you're
a cool dad kind of like the dad from
honey we checked the kids yeah yeah you
look like a director of like a big time
movie oh you cut the
sides yeah
you've always had like a really cute
boyish face that doesn't change it looks
a
you heard it here first totally [ __ ]
i look great like this
the checkout clerk actually recognized
me even without my hair do you actually
think this looks attractive
oh very sexy
oh man nobody seems to be giving two
shits about what i look like it's not
that big a deal or i'm
so ugly they can't even look at me my
neighbors might think i am a person
trying to break in
[Music]
it looks so real so do you think you
would still love me if i started losing
my hair like this i would love you to
matter what oh
would you love me if i started losing my
hair i would
[Music]
[Music]
out of control
as i adopted a more confident attitude
it became
easier to own my hairstyle and the
people that know you best are the people
that are gonna care the least people
fixate on their negatives and they they
get downtrodden by it but i think if you
look at your negatives and think of a
way to find positivity you can't choose
what happens to you but you can choose
what you do the biggest takeaway is that
my hair doesn't make up my identity bald
full ahead of hair whatever you are just
[ __ ] like yourself and [ __ ] anyone
else who says otherwise we started this
video by talking about how for men and
for me in particular this is probably my
biggest concern i've seen what that
might look like and it's really not that
scary so you're not mad at that
i see how it is so you like bald but not
balding that's how it is
you